j'assume mes actes eu la joie
brainstorming créatif ce matin pour
finger dredd aujourd'hui son ami lui a
laissé le champ libre pour peaufiner sa
coiffure
ils sont donc partis sur des extensions
forme de chaînes colorée à base de
cheveux naturels
voilà plusieurs mois que ce jeune
autodidacte a tressé savoie dans le
commerce de la boxe mais face à la forte
concurrence
il a très vite su qu'il devait se
démarquer ça a commencé à aller parler
lorsque à la base j'étais un chat
spécial liste des départs des passions
région et puis des réparations de luxe
et puis à force de réparer dès lors que
l'on donné un petit peu l'aspect que je
voulais un jour j'ai fait des boucles
par hasard pour une fille et je lui ai
dit pourquoi pas sur ip est ce qu'une
tendance s'est ensuite j'ai mûri le
projet et puis c'est en voyant une image
sur internet avec un bonhomme qui
avaient des chaînes dans sa tête ça m'a
beaucoup parlé j'ai cru que c'était du
moment par rapport à notre société
actuelle
et puis ça m'a donné envie de le faire
et la demande est là le salon est déjà
booké pour l'ensemble du mois
un succès qui s'explique par ses
créations originales comme la pose de
bijoux qu'il a lui-même dessiné au quand
même de la boxe j'ai commencé à mieux
l'idée depuis depuis la belgique avant
de lancer en martinique
et puis en arrivant ici j'ai commencé à
danser les premières pièces
effectivement sur ma tête j'en ai yeux
je n'ai jamais proposé une amie aussi et
puis après si j'ai continué j'ai
développé en initiant de dames ce n'est
des artistes ce qui m'a plu dans le
concept si le fait que ça soit original
au final pourquoi pas ce que c'est je
pense que le suivent lundi 1er août être
le premier à battre ses coiffures là
donc ça égaye beaucoup de curiosité
autour de moi et que les gens viennent
posent des questions ils se demandaient
mais comment justement ça c'est fait
comment qui est ce qu'il a fait puis
voilà derrière le début de succès
entrepreneurial jrc tient aussi à
changer le regard posé sur le cheveu
l'oxer se poser en ambassadeurs d'une
loque ce noble mais toujours haute en
couleurs